[Music]
good morning everyone union bosses are
accusing Ministers of stonewalling
requests for Meaningful pay talks as a
wave of winter strikes gains momentum
the TUC and Unison claim ministers are
refusing to negotiate in good faith in a
joint letter to the chancellor they've
insisted that no public sector workers
want to take industrial action borderful
staff are the latest to announce a walk
out over the Christmas period the
government is considering tough new laws
to limit strikes but they won't come in
time to stop the upcoming action
border staff strikes will affect several
airports from the 23rd of December to
the 26th then again from the 28th to the
31st but they're just the latest to
announce industrial action here we go
NHS workers are scheduled to walk out
for four days in December ambulance
staff on the 21st and the 28th nurses on
the 15th and the 20th in England Wales
and also in Northern Ireland keep up
with this rail strikes will take place
over four days next week with more
planned for January and new strikes
announced on Monday will start on
Christmas Eve and run until early on the
27th the day after boxing day six
o'clock in the morning on top of that
postal workers are planning a six day
strike
walkouts by some Scottish teachers which
begin yesterday will continue today and
driving test examiners security staff at
Eurostar some civil servants will also
go on strike this month 12th is looking
pretty optimistic for now but apart from
that there is a strike on every day of
December latest two
um announce is at Heathrow Airport
Saudia is there for us this morning
hello Saudia tell us more
well who can forget those long queues
that we saw at Heathrow Airport over the
summer when covered restrictions and
other factors left a staffing shortage
and lots of people's travel plans were
disrupted world just ahead of another
big holiday season more warnings of
travel chaos this time border Force
workers are due to strike at Heathrow
Airport London Gatwick Airport
Manchester Cardiff and Birmingham
they're going to start their strikes on
the 23rd right the way up to the
December 31st with only the exception of
December 27th when they're not going to
be striking so that's eight days of
action or you could say inaction during
what is one of the most busiest times of
the year to travel now the advice of
passengers is to check with your airline
before you travel but passengers can
expect things like long queues uh having
to turn up to the airport much earlier
than they anticipated and flight delay
so all of those things to look forward
to or not ahead of the holiday season
now Heathrow Airport is very keen to
emphasize is that passport control is
done not by its workers but by those
employed by border force and the union
who represents many of those employees
says that the strikes are designed to
have a significant impact but that
passengers should take their anger to
direct their anger towards the
government all of this is about a
dispute with the government to overpay
so the government refusing to budge from
that two percent pay increase the
workers wanting much much more which the
government says is simply unaffordable
at this time it says that it has enough
contingency plans in place to make sure
that any disruption to the public is
kept at a minimum but the union is
warning the government not to involve
the military of Defense the ministry of
Defense saying that they're just not
equipped or trained at this stage clock
goodness stay here we can tell you
what's happening now an Arctic Blast has
hit the UK which the Met Office says
will send temperatures plummeting to
minus 10 Celsius in some places by the
end of the week my goodness that's cold
Snow's Fallen overnight Scotland these
pictures were captured by traffic
cameras where the warnings for snow and
ice are in place there as well as
Northern Ireland Wales and the east
coast and Southwestern England over the
coming days let me tell you it was
absolutely freezing this morning minus
one when I got into my car this morning
so just how cold will it get let's find
out from Joe who's standing by for us um
hi Joe how cool will it be
yes like you said temperatures down to
-10 in some spots over the next few
nights where we've got snow cover that
will allow the temperatures to fall to
the lowest temperatures but yes a very
cold I feel we've got that Arctic air
mass across us now and it's bringing
very cold conditions over the next few
days wintry hazards as well with icing
the main Hazard over the next few days
but there will be some snow around and
like I said the wintry theme continuing
but
in the shop to the system we've had you
know the mild conditions we had through
November and Autumn but look at those
temperatures now we're seeing minus five
in places minus three and overnight we
did see minus 9.1 degrees Celsius in
Scotland so some very low temperatures
overnight and we will see temperatures
like these over the next few nights so
temperatures down to sort of minus six
minus seven in cold spots across the UK
and potentially like I said earlier
minus 10 where we've got the Slime snow
so ice is the main Hazard over the next
few days there will be some wintry
showers around for those postal areas
and perhaps moving Inland we've got
warnings in place we've got snow and ice
warning over Northern Scotland you could
see 10 to 15 centimeters of snow over
there held there and then ice warnings
for other parts of
you know
um and Northern Ireland as well and
Inland areas you know dry Sunny plenty
of sunshine it's just very cold we will
see daytime temperatures really own
around two or three degrees Celsius and
it will feel colder than that and with
brisk wind across
as well for wind chill there and some
cases perhaps staying at freezing and
and unfortunately the Cold theme is set
to continue into next week so keep the
longevity of this cold spell it's not
what people want at the moment
okay absolutely for now thank you
the Home Secretary swella bravman is in
Brussels this morning and is expected to
discuss further moves to reduce the
number of people trying to cross the
channel in small boats let's get more
should we add him standing by for us in
Brussels this morning what's the plan
Adam good morning
good morning yeah the sort of problem
has just arrived here in the past couple
of minutes right in the heart of
Brussels for a meeting about tackling
cross-channel migration it's a so-called
Calais format so this is a meeting of
interior ministers or home secretaries
from Britain from France Belgium
Netherlands Germany but also from
frontex who are in charge of running
borders across the European Union
europol European policing European
commission as well so it's a high level
meeting at this one to try I think to
put some more impetus into the
management of of cross-channel migration
remember recently the home office has
struck a fresh deal with French
authorities about providing more money
in order to bolster uh French activities
on the Northern French coaster we're
just awaiting about the French interior
ministers
second now but of course despite that uh
increased funding what we have seen
recently are record numbers of people
crossing the channel in those small
boats and some pretty strong rhetoric
coming as well from the Home Secretary
who refer to it as an invasion who has
consistently referred to these people as
a legal earning yourselves out to
rebukes from the United Nations who said
there's no such thing as an illegal
Asylum seeker and of course plenty of
people very upset about her using the
term Invasion she hasn't backed down on
on any of that rhetoric I think she's
going to come here and ask to see more
activity from uh from her French
counterpart Mr dominant but this isn't
just about the on the day this is about
long-term planning it's about how you
might address these people smuggling
gangs it's about how boats are being
brought to northern France and that is
why it is so important to have the
cooperation of the belgians the Dutch
the Germans and of course European
Security Services to try to stem this
problem at source then there will be
others who say well that if you're going
to stem it at source also going to look
at why people are are fleeing towards
Britain from Iran Iraq Eritrea Sudan and
so many other countries this is of
course an enormously contentious issue
and it's something that Sarah Brockman
has clearly put an awful lot of
political store by this time of year one
is getting cold used to be an enormous
dip you used to frankly not see any
migrants crossing the channel in small
boats at this time of year now there are
still people crossing and the French
just last night announcing that they
were going to station two more boats in
the area one of them a naval boat uh one
of them a customs vessel in order to
assist in any rescues it is just over a
year since more than 30 people died in
the channel as they tried to cross over
from France to Britain that will be on
people's minds so will those those
various political initiatives going to
be very interesting to see whether we
get just more words coming out of this
meeting or whether we actually see
concrete action okay for now thank you
thanks a lot
Vladimir Putin has that knowledge that
his forces could be fighting in Ukraine
for a long time but for now he won't be
calling up any more soldiers the Russian
president made his remarks during a
televised meeting with loyalists he also
warned that the threat of nuclear war is
growing but said Russia won't recklessly
threaten to use such weapons we haven't
gone crazy we are aware of what nuclear
weapons are we have these means and they
are in a more advanced and more modern
form than any other nuclear country this
is an obvious fact today but we are not
going to brandish this weapon like a
razor running around the world but of
course we proceed from the fact that it
is
almost a fifth of child deaths to sudden
unexpected and have no immediate cause
according to a report by England's
national child mortality database among
infants under a year old unexplained
death is significantly more likely in
the most deprived areas and it's often
associated with factors like low birth
weight larger families maternal smoking
and parental substance abuse
the government's assurances about
antibiotic supplies being questioned by
parents some pharmacies are now an MP
the health secretary Steve Barclay told
me yesterday that there's no concern
about shortages health services are
being stretched by strep a infections
which have been linked to the deaths of
nine children
the labor MP Darren Jones tweeted my
wife and I have had to visit eight
pharmacies in Bristol and in London
before we could get an urgent
prescription for kids antibiotics sorted
and now have 50 of what the GP asked for
and have been told to come back for the
rest reason a shortage of antibiotics
former U.S spy Anna sakulis is due to be
sentenced via video link today at the
old bayley for causing the death of
teenager Harry Dunn the circulus pleaded
guilty to careless driving in October
after hitting the 19 year old outside an
American Military Base in
northamptonshire in 2019. she left the
country soon afterwards citing
diplomatic immunity and any sentence
can't be enforced his parents have told
Sky they're still glad they fought for
justice
yeah totally
totally Nutley you know being able to
to tell him you know because we we do
talk to him
as I'm sure everyone does who's loved
one but
I think it was just a good thing that
I was seated in court because I think I
would have probably fallen down
because I just wanted to look up and
just say
we've done it Harry
never broken a promise to either of the
kids
and I sure as hell wasn't going to start
three years ago
education secretary Julian Keegan is
with us now good morning it's good to
see you thanks for joining
um what role does the government have to
accept in ruining people's Christmases
oh well
um this is just the most disappointing
news actually the fact that we've got
these strikes going on they're going on
over Christmas people are trying to see
their families you know we don't get
that much time to all come together and
so it's really really disappointing I
mean obviously this is
um you know between the unions and and
the paymasters we have actually
um accepted in full all of the
um recommendations from the from the
from the Independent bodies and you know
I I do understand I mean I think all of
us understand that inflation is high and
it's you know we've got this fight due
to you know obviously external factors
in the war in Ukraine but you can't
spend your way out of inflation what
we're trying to do is get that balance
and we've accepted all the
recommendations and we've urged
um you know people not to strike but uh
yeah it's very disappointing that border
force will be striking over Christmas we
can't get on a train we can't fly
there'll be problems on the roads
what are you going to do about it well
we are doing our best to to mitigate as
far as possible so in the case of Border
Force um we will have we've got 2 000
military personnel who are trained who
are going to try and mitigate or try and
help with some of those roles at the
border but you know we do expect there
will be disruption and just and delays
but they will do their best and they're
also helping with the Health Service as
well or if you not said yesterday
um he would do what he needs to do in
order to keep people safe what did he
mean
to keep people safe in regards well I'm
guessing he was suggesting that he would
bring in emergency measures so that
emergency services couldn't go on strike
well we have um got some emergency
measures which have been introduced to
Parliament and I think they're they're
looking at you know what we need to do
there but yes that has been mentioned
and we will he said he will put
legislation in place so I expect that
that will continue to be brought forward
yeah okay so emergency workers should
not be allowed to strike well I don't
know what the extent of the the I mean
some you know that some people are are
not allowed to strike I mean you know
there are some contracts which you know
say people can't strike I mean there are
I mean the military can't go on strike
for example
um and they're the people who obviously
um are helping us in in a last resort
but they is it fair that squadies who
earn significantly less than people who
are going on strike should be asked or
expected to fill in well I think we
should be extremely grateful for them
for doing that because I think also I
think they're they've accepted a pay uh
settlement which I think is is less and
lower than some of the others as well I
mean how much sympathy do you have for
people though like we've talked
previously about nurses using food banks
firemen are using food banks as well we
were told by their Union this week the
pay review bodies came up with their
figures but that was before inflation
was running at 11 yes and you know
inflation is affecting every single
person not just in this country actually
in many many other countries I mean the
obr obviously the most important thing
is you can't spend your way out of
inflation so try and navigate so that
you can bring inflation down if
inflation is high everybody feels poorer
and that's what we're trying to avoid to
to make that short as possible because
you can't just spend your way out of
that if we continue to do that then
we'll have inflation with us all for a
lot longer so it's really critical and
the obr I think saw inflation starting
to fall
um by you know sort of uh next year
um the early part of next year and all
the things we put in place you know the
energy relief scheme Etc I can't Heat
their homes well that's why we've got
the energy relief bill in place that was
55 billion pounds 55 billion pounds
worth of support just for for heating so
we are trying our best to get that
balance you know we're on a third of a
general strike I mean there's only one
day throughout the rest of December that
there isn't a strike in this country we
are on the verge of a general strike and
coordinated action by unions and we can
just look at that as we're chatting um
coordinated action by unions can bring
down governments
um well I mean that has happened in
history uh for sure um and you know
we're worried about that
you know you can only do what you can do
to try and control this you know you've
got two options haven't you you've
either got the option of trying to make
a fair and balanced approach because of
course you know if we if we accepted all
of the paid demands I think it's 28
billion pounds that taxpayers would have
to pay you know that's that's not
government money that's that's the other
taxpayers so you know what we're trying
to do is get this fair and balanced uh
approach now you know in terms of the
public sector I know teachers are
balloting at the moment you know that
five percent for an experienced teacher
which is on the bands by the way if you
move up the Bands then that can be more
than that and 8.9 for a um for a new
teacher so those are on the on the
starting salaries and we've raised the
starting salaries
yes it's not matching inflation
completely but inflation will go down
before the end of that Year's period if
we stick to our course and try to you
know take sensible measures as we
outlined in the budget this government's
on the precipice of a general strike
well I mean you know the reality is we
we have a number of people who are
striking and it's really disappointing
you know we have to pull together as a
country we've been through an awful lot
we've been through the pandemic we're
now supporting uh Ukraine in their war
against Russia these impacts these are
all things that are happening in every
country and they're not you know they're
not specific to our government at all
um you know all we can do is try to
react to those react to them in a fair
and balanced way we have accepted all of
the pay recommendations they are not at
inflation levels but they are you know
reasonable and they're highest in
teaching in the teachers pay rise is the
highest in 30 years that we're
recommending that we're agreeing is the
highest in 40 years yes it is but you
can't spend your way out of inflation
this is a really simple message if you
continue to spread your way out of
inflation it'll last for longer and
it'll impact everybody for longer and
that is where you get into these spirals
you can't get into a spiral we have to
take a sensible balanced approach we
have to navigate the country through
this it's really really disappointing
that people are striking and it's really
disappointing they're striking at
Christmas you know we've missed the last
two or three Christmases have been
completely disrupted due to the pandemic
you know people want to get together
with their families we don't get a lot
of time off this is a great time we all
try and catch up and everybody's plans
are being disrupted lots of us are
interconnected lots of us have you know
our eldest is in France you know lots of
people have
um people abroad and you know rely on
um the transport public transport to get
to see them I know you're here to talk
about funding for universities and
colleges um today
um there is concern that primary schools
are struggling though also to pay their
energy bills when they need to keep
those classrooms wrong because of fears
over strep a well that's why on Monday
this week
um or Monday or Tuesday I think you had
Nick Gibbon and we put in place at 500
million just for short-term energy
efficiencies within our schools so every
school has got an allocation which
they'll get very quickly to to do things
like lagging insulation
um heating controls LED lighting things
that will help them keep their bills
down obviously they also have the energy
relief scheme and we had two billion
pounds extra this year and next year
four schools they haven't had that money
yet but they'll be getting that they'll
find out their exact uh proportion of
that that they'll get by the end of the
year and they'll get it in April so
there is help it is on the way
um and you know we are working very much
and if anybody is particularly
struggling then they should get in touch
with the Department because you know we
do have people who will come and help
you work through how you you know get
those efficiencies in place a couple of
very short questions if I may apparently
the Albanian Ambassador was speaking uh
yesterday to the House of Commons
committee one of them um saying that
Albanian children are being bullied in
their schools because of a campaign of
discrimination by the Home Secretary
will you speak to her about the language
that you use oh I I haven't seen that
but you know bullying in schools you
know we completely are against any
bullying in schools and you know that
that isn't acceptable for anybody I
hadn't heard that report but I will look
back in the department and see if we've
had any reports of that but bullion is
you know is wrong anyway you know for
anybody for any uh whether it's the
where they come from or the color of
their skill or skin or whether they're a
girl or a boy it's completely
unacceptable okay
um will you miss Matt Hancock yeah I
mean I was his PPS for a while
um and I have worked with him uh in the
health department I mean you know by the
time I guess he goes you've done about
14 years of of service so I guess he's
decided I think it was pretty clear when
he went off to the Jungle that he was
probably thinking of a a a different
career it doesn't look as though it was
completely his choice though doesn't it
would have been deselected anyway well I
don't think anyone forced him to go the
jungle I mean I think I think that was
his choice yeah I meant stepping down
well you you know I think there's
I mean it was clear to me I think I said
at the time that that indicated to me
that he was perhaps looking to you know
take on a different career path um one
maybe more like yours I don't know get
your mitts off man it's good to see you
as always thanks very much
a quick look at the papers for you the
mail says it's looking a lot like a
general strike this Christmas after
another wave of industrial action was
announced yesterday
nearly a third of all flight departures
could be canceled as a result of airport
staff striking that's according to the
Times newspaper this morning and in the
telegraph senior military figures say
that Army staff should not have to miss
Christmas to cover for NHS staff on
strike
Tamara's here good morning morning Kay
well a minister is very disappointed in
the latest action by the board of force
and concedes there will be disruption
we've got eight days of strikes
announced by border guards at the key
airports the London airports Manchester
Birmingham Cardiff from the 23rd of
December right up to New Year's Eve so
there will be disruption to people's
flights people will be waiting longer in
passport queues as a result of that
action and Mark Sir whatker the head of
the PCS Union which represents most of
those border guards said it has been
time for Maximum Impact and says that
the government could solve it if they
negotiated on pay but looks very much
like that is going to go ahead the
government are considering all kinds of
things I'm told for legislation which is
expected to be announced in the new year
on strikes at minimum service levels
absolutely and the Prime Minister said
it yesterday at pmqs and from the
conversation I've had in government it
sounds as if all sorts of things are on
the table including further increasing
the threshold for strikes making some in
all blue light jobs basically ambulances
NHS staff and so on unable to strike but
it's not no decisions have yet been made
on where they're going to go with it but
it's expected to come soon but not soon
enough for these strikes over the
Christmas period tomorrow for now thanks
so much indeed thank you and former
footballer Carrie Bardsley joining
forces with the fa of great
and to get
into football than mayor of Greater
Manchester Andy Burnham is with us now
hello to Mr Burnham thanks for joining
us on the program this morning more
girls into football given that the
lionesses brought it home surely it's a
no-brainer
uh you would think so you would hope so
okay wouldn't you uh but here in Greater
Manchester we certainly don't forget the
letter that the lionesses uh sent to the
the then leadership candidates Rishi and
Liz back in the back in the summer
making quite a simple call that all
girls growing up should uh by right have
the chance to play football during their
two hours of PE in school and at the
moment only about two-thirds do so a
third don't get that opportunity so
Grace Minister the capital of football
we want to set the way and we're writing
to all schools today myself and Karen
and uh some of the other members of the
great monster women's football board to
say come on let's do this let's let's do
this first and and set the standard all
girls the chance to play football
growing up when they're at school that's
the way to go to build on the lionesses
success you set up the Greater
Manchester women's football board I
think I'm writing saying in June how's
that going oh it's going really well I
mean everyone's knew Karen before but I
think they've probably got to know more
this year so she's chairing at the board
we've got lots of people on it we're
just determined to make sure that the
success that the lionesses had in the
summer becomes a permanent Legacy I
think it is I can feel that already and
obviously what's going on now with the
the men's World Cup only reinforces that
it's amazing isn't it okay the change
we've seen with regard to uh women in
football the promotion of women and
girls football uh but let's not leave it
to chance let's not let those summer
memories fade uh let's turn it into real
change for uh girls and young women
growing up now and that's what we're
determined to do in Greater monster
I think there's a big Clash on Sunday in
the women's Super League Manchester City
Manchester United playing at the Etihad
Stadium
um it's this weekend a good chance to
push women's football for the region as
well yeah absolutely that's going to be
a huge game that the Etihad on Sunday uh
City versus United and ahead of that
okay we're holding a Civic reception uh
this evening myself and the leader of
Manchester City Council and some of the
Civic Mayors because we want to make
sure that what was achieved in the
summer really isn't forgotten we hope
the men are about to repeat it of course
but this feels a good moment to just
honor the lionesses with a Civic
reception uh but also as we look forward
to that massive Manchester Derby at the
weekend uh you know the country needs a
lift okay doesn't it uh the lionesses
gave us that lift let's hope obviously
um we'll be we'll be seeing the same
constantly night and hopefully the men
going on to Victory as well okay just
checking my dare I can't see that I had
an invite to that reception there we go
you were celebrating it last weekend as
well weren't you all for a good cause
but we did see um Angela Rainer on the
decks
yeah yeah she was born to I was like no
she was brilliant to be honest you know
it was all uh for
um our homelessness at charity and we're
seeing sadly us like rise in the number
of people sleeping rough I think linked
to the cost of living crisis so ahead of
the winter we said right let's raise
some money a DJ battle Manchester versus
Liverpool you can imagine uh what that
was like okay it was brilliant actually
though Steve Rotherham came over brought
some special guests Angela was my
special guest I asked her to go but she
really uh gave everybody a real a real
lift and to be honest people say oh we
should she be doing it should I be doing
it when you're the mayor of Greater
Manchester you're you're the mayor
obviously of the home of music and if
you're not getting on the decks you're
not doing your job
um I don't know if you were at the event
that kirstama was at in Leeds um talking
about Devolution a two-year report is
that really the thing to get
um voters pulses racing ahead of the
next election
I was really pleased uh to see uh Gordon
and Care standing there promising uh to
rewire the country because we're not
going to ever level up this country if
we don't change the way it works and
make sure places like the north of
England have more power I mean it's what
it all comes down to to honest power
it's the fundamentals if you're going to
make this country fairer you're going to
have to rewire it first so I was really
pleased to see that commitment you know
I was with the German ambassador on
Tuesday okay in Germany in the
Constitution there is a law that says
all of the regions of Journey must have
equivalent living standards and there is
a redistribution of funds across Germany
to always ensure that that is what
happens the same standard of Transport
in all parts of Germany imagine can you
imagine if we have a law in the UK that
all parts have to have equivalent living
standards can you imagine what a
different country we would be today if
that have been in place for decades as
it has been in Germany so yes this is
this is a prerequisite to making this
country fairer and more equal and it may
not set everyone's pulses going but but
it but it does mine and I was really
pleased to see it okay
um quick uh question before I let you go
we're almost out of time uh this coke
mine that's opening in Whitehaven are
you in favor
I can't help but feel it it's a backward
move it's time to embrace the future I
understand why people there will feel
it's the right the right way to go but
build Industries now that will last not
a decade or two but a century and you
know the the potential for renewable
energy in Cumbria is massive uh so
that's that's what I would I would say
okay uh Embrace embrace the future
um and that's what we're trying to do in
Greater Manchester you know build build
a green economy because the jobs in the
in the green economy will be there for a
century or more
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks a lot thank you enjoy this
evening weren't you oh yes we certainly
will pass on your best to them okay take
care thank you
back to our top story for you now two
million passengers using some of
Britain's busiest airports over the
festive season could face long delays
and possibly flight cancellations the
cause a strike by border force staff
joining us now from Heathrow to discuss
this further and the impact that it's
going to have on your holiday plans is
Simon Calder travel editor for the
independent of course hi it's good to
see you thanks for joining us this
morning how worried should we be about
Christmas being ruined
well look okay as you know I'm always
trying to be as positive as possible
travel is the industry of human
happiness but right now I'm looking very
very concerned about well we simply
don't know what will happen let me take
you through what the scenario could be
on Friday the 23rd of December that's
the first day of the strike now as you
know you don't have your passport
checked when you're leaving the country
it's just coming in but we're right now
in the middle of the big wave of
arrivals those planes have been coming
in since well before 5 a.m today and
you've got uh tens of thousands of
people coming into he throw the busiest
in Europe among airports and if those
people start building up if Q start
building up in the arrivals Hall then
you're gonna have to hold the passengers
on the plane you've been on a flight for
hours but you're still stuck there
that's annoying but actually what it
then does means that those flights
cannot turn around and leave full of
passengers so passengers in the
Departures area will build up then
you're not going to have any gates for
the other incoming flights so that's
when
um diversions and cancellations begin
and what we've been seeing overnight is
that the director general of the UK
border Force has contacted the aviation
industry and said we really need to talk
about proactive cancellations of up to
30 percent of flights so that we don't
get chaos at Britain's airports and that
of course if you've got a booking for
Christmas well I'm afraid if it's from
Heathrow Gatwick Manchester Birmingham
Glasgow or Cardiff at this stage I can't
absolutely swear that it's going to go
ahead as you imagine
oh that's not great is it what happens
if your flight's canceled
well if if I may if if your flight is
canceled well it's very very clear under
European air passenger rights rules the
airline has to get you to your
destination as soon as possible even if
that means buying a flight on another
airline but look as we have seen you
might remember the drone incident at
Gatwick a few years ago
um if there is disruption at Christmas
um with hundreds sometimes thousands of
flights canceled then you could there
simply aren't the seats available to get
people there now I really don't want to
spread any upset or concern but people
have already been getting in touch with
me some of them are saying look can I I
really don't want the uncertainty can I
just cancel my flight my holiday and get
a full refund well no at the moment you
won't because of course all the airlines
want to fly as normal
um I've been in touch with the other big
airports Manchester say we're expecting
disruption we're expecting cancellations
Gatwick down in Sussex second busiest in
the UK say actually
um we think that there aren't going to
be any effects on flights so
um let's hope that they are right and
everybody gets through this but um right
now on top of the chaos of course on the
railways um it's a very very uncertain
time for travelers just a quick thought
about Eurostar
uh Euro star actually not looking too
bad we've got threatened strikes on the
16th on the 18th on the 22nd and the
23rd of uh December that will affect
people possibly going out of London some
Pancras that security staff however that
may well be sorted out and the UK border
Force action is not going to affect
people who are heading either on
Eurostar or Euro tunnel that's the car
carrying service and it's not going to
affect the main way in and out of the UK
which is the port of Dover okay great to
see you thanks very much for joining us
thanks a lot
thank you
some glimmers of Hope there I think from
Simon Britain witnessing the worst
squeeze on incomes though in a
generation new figures shared with scan
you suggest 4.3 million low-income
households and are struggling to afford
day-to-day Essentials and have fallen
behind with their bills all year our
people in politics correspondent Nick
Martin has been following the struggle
of families battling to keep their heads
above water and has this special report
I've not had anything to eat since
breakfast
I've got no money to get any food or get
any drink
really hit me now how bad things are
really are
I've got 20p
to my name
that's it
Danielle and her two children Brooke and
bryony have struggled through this
entire year life's Essentials like gas
electric and food now so expensive they
often go without
heating my fire is the only source of
heat
I feel like we've gone back in time
every day it's just another fight it's
just
what are they going to eat today how am
I going to keep the house warm
how am I going to get them to school how
am I gonna you know just
just
trying to get through one day at a time
and it's a struggle
in your wallet yeah
I know who art get that from
hey
thank you
according to the Joseph Roundtree
Foundation as the year nears its end 4.3
million low-income households have
fallen behind on their bills and are
going without an essential like food
warm clothing or even prescriptions and
three million low-income households
haven't been able to heat their homes
and that's before the predicted cold
weather next week
the average low-income family is in
arrears of over 1 600 pounds with 2.4
million now relying on credit to pay
their bills
I've got a six pound 63 emergency
remaining and I owe seven pound eighteen
the month's just
enough and then gas wise that's outside
and I hate I haven't even looked at it
recently because I didn't you will
suddenly quid yep
so you're in debt to the gas and you're
into the electricity yeah and I haven't
even got anything emergency wise on the
gas so your gas is off at the moment
yeah you've got no gas no gas
because I can't afford to repay that
right now
at night I struggled to get to sleep
because I think what if this time next
year I'm not in this place what if I'm
in a completely different place or I'm
in a homeless shelter or I'm out on the
streets or something
like other households Danielle's
received government support to help pay
for her electric but she's still
struggling this is where I spend all of
my evening my little heater goes on
before bed
and as soon as I get up in the morning
to try and make it more bearable it's my
safe place but it's also my worst place
everything hits me when my kids are in
bed
so it is it's my sanctuary and my dark
place
I don't know how I'm gonna face
Christmas if I'm completely honest I
think it is going to be the case of
little little things that cost nothing
but
it's all I can do I can't plan for
tomorrow I just gotta just deal with it
when it comes
Danielle is now falling behind on the
rent
she's coming to terms with a stark
reality she no longer has enough money
to live on Nick Martin Sky News
leicestershire
back to those strikes now in an upcoming
industrial action will also affect the
ports uh these holidays as well Richard
Valentine is the CEO of the British
sports Association hi good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning how do you expect
um action to impact on the ports
morning Kay uh pleased to be with you
again it's nice to see it's been a
little while I think last time we talked
about brexit so it's always kind of um
quite exciting times I guess when we we
speak to people like you
um we're not expecting a huge deal of uh
disruption at the moment the indication
from border force uh um at present is
that uh it's going to primarily affect
airports although one Seaport New Haven
has been specified in their list of
ports that could uh see some you know
real impacts
Etc but we're waiting for that 14-day
notice and I'd have to say we do
sympathize with those who are going on
strike and we understand the current
pressures and we've seen industrial
action across the economy uh and we do
understand why it's happening but
obviously looking at uh mitigating any
impacts of our ports and borders
um yeah I mean we we do often see when
there's a challenge a big long queues at
the likes of uh Dover how how prepared
are we to deal with that this time
well I think we're in a fairly good
place I'd say border Force have been as
you can expect have been all over this
this is uh you know critical importance
to the home office uh there's lots of
contingency uh planning going on uh
obviously we don't fully have all the
details yet PCS has uh that 14-day
notice period to comply with so once
we're a little bit closer to the 40 days
from the 30th 23rd sorry I think we'll
know a little bit more
um we have had several conversations
with the Border four some of those are
in confidence but it's clear that
they've got lots of mitigating uh
arrangements and measures they've
trained uh parts of the army understand
to mano uh passport controls so we're
we're fairly confident there should be
minimal impacts but obviously I think
it's sensible for everyone in sector
also travelers to to work out what the
impacts may be on any Journeys they plan
to take what's your advice to anybody
who might be uh thinking about you to
traveling via the ports over the
Christmas period
well I'd keep an eye on all the advice
from people like the Border force in the
home office and also the carriers I
think that's the key so if they've
booked either with uh Airline operators
or with Ferry operators I think it's
worse worth following uh what the advice
is from those carriers on websites Etc
and hopefully uh there'll be minimal
impacts but I think it's obviously worth
paying close attention to what the the
news is there
okay um it's good to talk to you thanks
for taking the time much appreciated
thank you
thanks guys
I've been telling you about plummeting
temperatures haven't we minus one this
morning when I got up right across the
UK of problems and raising concerns for
those experiencing homelessness severe
weather emergency protocol has been
activated meaning emergency
accommodation will be provided for rough
sleepers Rebecca Sycamore from Saint
mungo's homeless charity is with us now
hi good morning one of the challenges
you're facing well it is as you said
very very cold out there this morning
and over the night and our teams have
been out getting people off the streets
making sure that they're in a safe warm
place to sleep I think that you know we
are you know continually worried the
weather's not getting better it is still
really cold we need to keep the focus on
getting people off the streets really
quickly making sure they can stay inside
um also you know being warm during the
day as well so it's not just about
somewhere to sleep it's about the
daytime temperatures and making sure
that people are in warm spaces where do
you put them so we have a whole range of
extra beds that are triggered some of
them are emergency bed spaces some of
them are spaces that we normally are
vacant for some other reason they might
be kind of spaces that are you know not
normally bedrooms but we can make
available as a kind of a place a safe
warm place for people to sleep and
people might be sleeping in in you know
in offices in in some of our existing
accommodation projects hostels so a
whole range of places you know we are
we're very inventive and creative about
what we can use and that homeless people
want to take you up on the offer or do
some of them still want to stay on the
street I mean I was talking to a
colleague last night and she said that a
lot of people were saying yes they
wanted to come in cold too cold people
you know have you know other health
problems uh you know they've got kind of
you know maybe more susceptible to
respiratory conditions because of being
out on the streets for longer so yeah
people were saying yes and wanting to
come in so that that was really positive
actually and do you do you give them
food yep sure so you know uh yeah warm
food uh you know see what people need
and then I think once we have people in
that's not the end of it that's the
start so then and we have an opportunity
to to ask them and to work with them
about what what it would take to keep
them in for longer so it's always it's
always about using that opportunity and
how long do you offer them well so it
kind of it depends we hope that if
people
um come in that we can stay we can keep
them in for a few days for the start if
there's a relatively quick solution for
their homelessness or their rough
sleeping then then we can progress that
some cases can be really complicated and
we may try and hold on to people but you
know people might want to go back out
again but it is a start of a
relationship which I think is is really
valuable right now though it's
definitely about kind of saving people's
lives and getting them off the streets
if they stayed I I mean it's freezing
um people are sleeping on kind of
Pavement in you know shop doorways on
the streets it's it's not the time to be
out on the streets I think it is really
really really dangerous what can people
do to help so uh if people want to have
there's um an app and a website called
Street link and you can let us to know
about people who are sleeping on the
streets in your area and we'll take that
information and pass it on to local
teams and they will go out and try and
find people and so you can be our eyes
and ears and getting people off the
street
um how many people do you think you
might be able to help during this period
I don't know I mean I think I'm at the
teams I've spoken to will want to
they'll have lists of people that
they're really worried about they will
want to get everybody off straights I
know kind of it's not just in London
it's not just in London I was just about
to say I was talking to people in we
were talking to people in Bristol last
night and they were still working at
midnight getting people off the streets
so
and when people are off the streets you
do what you can to try to make sure they
don't go back but some will yeah some
will but then our Outreach teams will be
will be there working with them anyway
and and so will other Outreach teams
around the rest of the country it's you
know we're not just there when the cold
weather we we're there every day of the
year of course and um given that the
prediction is we'll have a look at the
weather in a second actually but given
that the prediction is that it's going
to be a bitterly cold winter I what do
you do about funds well we're I mean
we're starting uh we've got plans for
this you know it is tight we are under
for financial pressure there's lots and
lots of Charities are and so we're doing
everything we can to raise money to to
kind of get the services and to be able
to carry on running Services working
with our local authorities as well and
working with colleagues so that we're
clever about resources but it's it's a
real strain we are you know we are
struggling it's a tough time of year at
the end of the day do you feel that you
have potentially saved people's lives or
do you feel I can't believe that so many
people live off or both both I mean the
Outreach teams have done amazing work
they will have worked really late last
night they will be out this morning they
will be saving people's lives and they
will be delighted that they're able to
work with people and to get people into
safety but we will all be thinking you
know we this this isn't we need we need
not to be doing this as well you know as
important that is we have to kind of you
know work towards a sustainable solution
yeah Street link if you see somebody new
uh anxious that they may need help go to
Street thing it's good to see you thanks
very much